bien bonjour et bienvenue en direct
d'angoulême pour ce superbe trophée
roses à l'allemand championnat de france
rapide féminin angoulême 2018
petite vidéo de lancement avec on le
voit là si l'image arrêté de de
l'édition de l'an passé la victoire de
maria le conte ici qui jouait face à
minot hommage aux razzias lecomte tenant
du titre qui sera bien elle présente
pour défendre son titre donc
eh bien ce sera un championnat en deux
jours samedi demain et dimanche donc ça
me dit sur la chaîne i mean aux échecs
partenaires diagonale tv et dimanche la
suite du tournoi sur la chaîne diagonale
tv n'oubliez pas de de marquer vos
abonnements si vous voulez suivre ce
direct pour samedi ça va démarrer vers
15h 15h30 peut-être ces heures ci un peu
de retard mais vers 15h30 normalement le
direct et dimanche toute la journée à
partir de 9h 9h30 vérifier ça sur le
site officiel vous allez sur diagonale
tv.com bien sûr et vous aurez tous les
détails pour suivre ce très beau
championnat de france rapide féminin
angoulême 2018 avec la présence de
pauline guichard ces silos cerneaux sera
la marianne conditions tenant du titre
nino maso radier sera là andrien a voté
ce coût sera la voilà donc vraiment les
stars féminines
il ya manque que très peu pour faire un
très bel événement à suivre pour le
titre de champion de france rapide a
très vite donc à partir de demain samedi
et dimanche à partir de 9h30 samedi
15h30
voilà à bientôt à bientôt sur des
monotypes